então quando eu tinha seis anos de idade
é minha mãe me colocar no ceará
ela me colocou no céu e e duas semanas
eu saí porque eu tinha sérios problemas
de socialização era muito tímido não
conseguir falar com os garotos estavam
conseguindo seguir assim mãe olha só eu
não gosto de falar lá não gosta da
escola mas eu te juro eu aprendi sozinho
aprender a ler sozinho vou poder fazer
quando fazer a minha mãe a vida pra mim
fazem eu sair é mesmo pouca ela é doida
ela deixou sair do ceará estudar sozinho
eu então é começar a aprender a ler e
tal com até fiquei em casa tava sozinho
o ano passou do próximo ano ela começou
a procurar alguma escola para entrar no
primeiro ano ensino fundamental e aí
procurando escola pré escolas e escolas
não não tem diploma é que ele tem que
acontecer a não tem como não dá pra
entrar não vai acompanhar os seguranças
sérios
[Música]
ela não queria ter gente tava certo
porque ele estava falando isso pra minha
mãe é muito uma lábia
ela compra ela consegue comprar uma
camisa de você fazer você pagar ainda e
ela conseguiu convencer uma uma escola
aceitar fazer o primeiro ano do ensino
fundamental sem diploma fosse meu filho
é muito inteligente
meu filho pode entrar lá ele vai ser
esforçado mais inteligente ele vai
ganhar tudo
aí fui não é cheguei lá a passeio ano
estudante legal que o negócio do colégio
e foi quando eu gostei mais
e aí como acabou o ano com isso aqui é
uma medalha de alunos de melhor
performance de coragem
achei legal será que realmente a gente
precisa de pontos para as coisas não
estão noiado com isso foi cada um
procurar no dicionário sex bomb era
similar era sinônimo alguma coisa
parecida com educação você pode até
olhar tem uma relação
o homem educação direta eu quero não
achei
hoje em dia eu pergunto muito gosto de
um time muito bom fazer essa pergunta
pra vocês vocês quiseram o querem de
roma pra que realmente precisa de como
eu vou tentar falar um pouco da sombra a
o que a sociedade falou um pouco pra
vocês
a sociedade a pressão societário ela diz
assim olha só com diploma aumentar a
chance de emprego você ganha mais
respeito à reputação dinheiro educação é
tudo ótimo
e aí começa seus pais pressão na cabeça
olha meu filho você não vai chegar a
lugar algum sem carro na mão orgulho
estabilidade e exemplo de transformação
a vida seja vai ser muito mais fácil sem
estresse muito grande depressão
a educação é tudo para o seguinte eu vou
mostrar que começamos a assistir pra
vocês
steve jobs criador da apple patrimônio
de 10 bilhões de dólares quando ele
morreu
randy externa brasileira fundador da
h.stern patrimônio 6 milhões 5 santos de
3 milhões
oprah winfrey mark zuckerberg fichas de
imprensa ou r ford eo game cordel todo
mundo todos esses caras quando você olha
para todos esses acho que a gente não
tiver educação as taxas não foram
educados
eu digo que nenhum deles nenhum deles se
formou em alguma instituição superior de
ensino se é que pode se chamar seu de
superior mas é algo que você pode chegar
a mim falar assim essa ajuda
dinheiro não é a única nem a melhor
média processo
a gente chega pra mim fácil era só é eu
não faço por dinheiro é faltar tudo bem
o dinheiro você faz pra que seja pra que
por amor é pra ajudar o próximo ajudar o
pessoal então se for pra isso também
aqui são paulo e estatística paulo de
jesus cristo sócrates mas teresa de
calcutá mal com ex-marido jackson
michael jordan
beethoven e shakespeare thomas edison e
um deles fez por dinheiro nenhum deles
se formou em nenhuma instituição
superior
nenhum deles conseguiu diploma e eles
não são educados
ainda assim vocês podem falar assim olha
só tudo que falam sobre acesso sem
diploma ao conseguir alguma coisa sem
diploma é sempre calado estados unidos é
uma coisa muito grande fica muito longe
não consigo ficar olhando esse negócio
de ficar muito longe de mim e eu
concordo
olha eu vou falar um pouco sobre a minha
história eu não sei nem uma pessoa de
grande sucesso está fazendo uma ótima ou
excelente prova
eu gostaria de mostrar que o caminho que
eu tô fazendo pra vocês militar também
está é a seguinte em 9 de fevereiro de
1990 minha vida começava a câmera lenta
a família grande pequena mesmo tempo
pobre índios negros e portugueses mas
ninguém nunca ter completado o ensino
médio
eu quero ser tímido muito tímido sem
falar sofria bullying depressão até já
tentei me matar minha mãe ela criava
gente nova no complexo do alemão a tirar
eu e meus irmãos sem dinheiro sem na mão
já passei fome ela já foi cortada várias
vezes na minha casa eu tive nenhum longe
mas eu gostava muito de estudar bastante
e estudar mas gostava de quebrar alguns
brinquedos mexendo robozinho e no livro
de ortopedia da minha mãe que não é
médica mas ela auxiliar de enfermagem
não gostava dessas coisas mas ainda que
gostaria de estudar de um problema muito
grande que era ela não conseguia
controlar as emoções
eu as pressões tudo e deixava muito
baseado até que por muita sorte digo
sorte quando tinha 10 anos de idade
é um time apresentou um tipo de
meditação chamada mais diferença
na época eu via como vi passa né e aí
essa meditação é uma técnica baseada
você começar a prestar atenção nas suas
sensações de forma intencional
de momento a momento nem passado nem
futuro é agora estou sentindo agora
estímulos externos também agora
sem jogar é bom e saboroso prazeroso só
preciso atenção com mau humor bem
curioso é bem senti em o'bama a
característica curiosa do cientista se
você olhar para você mesmo
parece bobeira mas com isso eu consegui
começar a controlar as emoções
tá não pára de passar fome tinha um
amigo meu que morreu na escola tinha
problema de richa de gigante no complexo
do alemão onde morava e as palavras ea
não amanhã pode não fechava o caixa do
estabelecimento porque vai ter guerra
que alemã cruzeiro
isso não mudou continuava no entanto a
minha resposta a todos os problemas
tragicamente praticamente então o mar
que me ajudou a trabalhar as emoções
acontecer - a pressão no entanto tinha
um fator ainda que eu não conseguia
resolver ainda era muito tímido muito
tímido e eu tinha muita vergonha de
falar muita vergonha de falar eu não
sabia que era isso que eu entrei no
ensino médio ensino médio e fazer o
técnico em patologia clínica estava lá
eu estava indo para a escola eu vi no
jornal um anúncio
aos 15 anos de idade o anúncio de uma
falha de uma palestra numa universidade
aqui no rio de janeiro que eu não
conhecia qual era mais novo era a
maneira que o nome do palestrante também
nome parecia não ser usual levar um nome
legal assim não parece legal não
aparecer muito legal e ilegal
então eu falei com um amigo meu uma
escola assim vamos vamos a palestra vai
ser muito maneiro e tal
a gente chegou lá de tomar radão começou
a ver o tema começou a estudar o tema
deixe de ajudar a gente não sabe inglês
não pegava os artigos em inglês a
palavra a palavra traduzir a palavra
livre que liberava muitos estudantes no
segundo dia da palestra a gente chegou
na escola saiu mais cedo outra estava lá
no jardim américa
sai do jardim américa foi lá pra essa
universidade chinesa universidade é uma
coisa tão bonita assim que era oferecido
ajuda grande e aí um salão assim para
tribunal antigo e lá no fundo tinha o
velhinho era professor que estava
organizando tudo
o nome do ciclo de palestras é coppélia
vamos ver se o professor está
organizando moisés vai me em nome dessa
universidade universidade federal do rio
de janeiro
lá eu cheguei queria fazer a pergunta
foi assistir às palestras que eram muito
um nível muito alto e até que chegue
taboa palestra do mês e ficar ao meu
deus vou fazer pergunta foi levantar
montar e desmontar aqui a ele para ver a
brincar e já era a mesma coisa o
trabalho dela saindo pela boca quase
morrendo eu não vou tentar vou ter que
falar na frente não falou com ninguém de
falar no microfone nervoso nervoso
quando cheguei lá
levantei cheguei para treinar quase caí
peguei o microfone eu peguei o microfone
para cada tarefa
quando eu fiz isso eu aprendi foi o
primeiro a pedir realmente a me conectar
de fato ser ouvido sem nenhum tipo de
julgamento
o professor mas ele ficou espantado por
eu ter feito a pergunta aly professores
tão nobre professores da ufrj de fora do
país
alguns prêmios nobel e fields também de
matemática está fazendo perguntas não
saber que ela disse que na palha na
platéia tinha era composta por pega
desde os docs e professores e os 15 anos
ele falou em todo mundo levanta e
balança para garotos e assim certamente
foi uma das melhores coisas na minha
vida foi um tipo de reconhecimento onde
eu não sabia sair não sabe falar não
conseguir falar de vergonha de falar pra
quando eu falei no meio de vários
intelectuais que não era não era minha
convivência
todos bateram paulo reconheceu então
aquilo ali foi um grande divisor de
águas na minha vida
após a linha outra palestra quando fui
fazer pergunta de novo o pesquisador
chamou pra dar pra trabalhar no
laboratório dele não foi problema para
história dele aqui no rj
comecei a trabalhar depois de um tempo
você aprende bastante consegui minha
própria linha de pesquisa aí
antes de entrar na faculdade conseguir
terminar de pesquisa orientada
o ano e dá aula para pós graduação sem
mesmo diploma de ensino médio
e aí depois eu comecei mesmo dessas
corre corre corre e tinha uma pressão
muito grande todo mundo achando que era
muito inteligente
não era só com mágicas que eu fazia não
sabia controlar as emoções e visualizar
as coisas direito e eu ia dizer uma
palavra
mas não era inteligente então quem é que
a gente pode estar com um tipo de
inteligência nessa pressão eu tava pra
fazer o vestibular
todo mundo já passou já passamos aqui
talvez não tinha tempo pra ajudar
particular porque ficava no laboratório
de inteiro saía ia para o colégio
faltava outro incremento no laboratório
rs ro
o caso não está agindo no passado em ser
então parei de novo e mais mexeu
novamente no qual conseguiram fazer a
prova e ajudava quando conseguia dentro
do colégio a entender que está pensando
comigo nas relações e de toda a
arquitetura e ao fazer a prova eu
consegui começar a visualizar já
passando a pj então eu estava fazendo a
prova sabe que entrar está visualizando
isso é besteira mas já que isso funciona
sempre adoro fazer isso funcionar eu
passo aí comecei a fazer meus filhos que
sempre que se quer fazer o pré
vestibular devem fazer física na
biofísica eu gostava de matemática
comecei a fazer matemática aplicada
junto também
e aí fazendo benefício matemática
aplicada quase pirei já falei verdade é
grande pra caramba
aí comecei a pegar matéria do marketing
da psicologia da filosofia sociologia
moda tudo eu vim aqui como um potencial
de 30 coisa que aprender que gostava de
muita coisa
eu comecei a fazer tudo isso tudo isso
dito isso a chegada dele pra mim
gil vai formar está internada na
maternidade era ter uma hora que comecei
a querer montar a empresa para levantar
empresa rico mas eu saí com uma semana
na empresa e aí comecei a montar a
empresa pega a matéria de marketing que
é interessante já comecei com um
conector os professores e tauá tem hora
que eu falei pô eu vou ficar aqui porque
é porque tem contato de business cartão
dinheiro então estou tranqüilo aqui já
estou lá para buck fiz lá quatro meses
para fazer contato com os alunos e os
professores contato com o tema j o
titular de novo
cheguei aqui esse é o tamanho da terra
eu falei cara faz isso de novo começa a
pegar uma matéria com tecnologia
psicologia disse que está tudo isso a
empresa já foi dando certo foi bem legal
porque a empresa melhore interessantes
que ela eu quando eu comecei a empresa
eu tava rpm e uma vez aqui no rj teve um
concurso para a finlândia assim o
ganhador é pra finlândia para finlândia
só que eu não tinha diploma os casos que
apresentaram investidores e townsend
prudencial xixi monte de coisa eu não
sabia nada no entanto através dessas
pessoas pessoas não são puramente
racionais
então se eu mas eu pegar o contato de
todo mundo e mandar uma apresentação pra
eles subconscientemente manter contato
com aquela ali na hora de uma avaliação
tem a predileção de tv band foi a
primeira vez que eu fui pra sair do país
sabe assim foi uma sexta-feira para
fazer essa viagem não tinha passaporte
comecei em três dias a conseguir uma
carta com diziam lutador ministério da
ciência tecnologia e educação a da
finlândia está em 68 do brasil conseguir
tudo tá pra conseguir um pacote de
emergência não me deram a desenrolar-se
em lei
perdi o o o evento o primeiro dia só que
o meu passaporte chegou eu falei cara
desse passaporte agora eu consigo pegar
a conexão aqui cheguei a madrid em madri
se eu fizer um destaque com ele consigo
fazer minha primeira omer bhatti na
primeira sessão da negociação
depois continuou chegar lá e falei pra
ele está louco para jogar eu faço por
skype planeja só começar para o skype
seu passado continuam chegar e cheguei a
vê-lo feliz ao saber que consumir avião
ele quebrou eu voltei e voltei eu
cheguei que eu voltei fiz um barraco na
no aeroporto e eles me deram desde a
oportunidade de conseguir pra só tinha
vaga na primeira classe do fim
eu fui na classe para a finlândia
cheguei lá e eles não têm muita coisa
voltei fui para londres uma porrada de
coisa pra onde morei lá law deixem eu
sair da empresa onde ela
depois eu comecei a virar setor de baixo
valor que escolas
eu não acredito demais não têm escolas
rotear feliz chega no brasil a pessoa
chega pra mim fácil transformar o itabom
aí saí de lá voltei com quem comecei a
fazer um monte de coisa aprendi a falar
com pessoas agora se falava de vocês não
têm vergonha monte de coisa
o pessoal ainda perguntava você vai
formar e sinceramente a gente passa
tanto tempo preocupado com esse sistema
que parece pressurizado de baseado em de
bombas que a gente raramente para
prestar atenção em sons diplomas são só
papéis é jeito nós somos humanos
você acha justo que vários estudantes
aqui ele sofreu de ansiedade gastrite e
depressão
há muito tempo o suicídio o sistema mas
é na pressão do povo somente de coma
é como eu sinto como se pegasse o
potencial de todo mundo aqui e
precisasse passar se um outro lado o
diploma passando por ele e reduzindo o
papel bidimensional e isso me faz muito
mal a nós nenhum de nós aqui estamos
somente de uma banal
somos muito mais 15 educação não é
definido por escola e não é assim não é
não adianta você tirar desta idéia é ser
feliz não sabe falar com os amigos não
sabe fazer conexão que tinham de se
tirar dez não sabem aplicar na sua vida
fica diante as coisas que você não pode
servir cheio de antidepressivos está
desmatando
não é porque vocês todos têm acesso à
história dos escolares a nossa vida é
realmente a minha saúde mental e as
regras todos nós aqui temos potencial
para fazer qualquer coisa que qualquer
coisa inclusive com o diploma não é
exclusivo
então eu queria dizer que o diploma ele
não é exclusivo ele assim você não é
ruim ser rebelde vai deixar a faculdade
acabou
você pode usar a faculdade como sistema
maravilhoso maravilhoso de conexão
você consegue encontrar várias pessoas
diferenciadas lugar só de tudo quanto é
canto
então para aqueles que são os mais
loucos os desajustados peças
a glaxo redondos é estranho não sei quem
pensa diferente
o meu apelo é use a universidade não
somente os rebeldes rebate legal mas a
universidade não fazer conexões olhar
para cada pessoa não só professor
contato profissional mas cada pessoa
cada colega da turma cada funcionário
cada pessoa cada pessoa de coração
aberto e fazer conexão das pessoas é
isso ea coragem de chegar lá e fazer é
que pode você não precisa de diploma se
vocês não quiserem declarou
na verdade a capacidade de vocês
conseguirem fazer qualquer coisa quero
fazer sempre sai de bola é diretamente
proporcional à qualidade das conexões
não a quantidade mas a qualidade das
conexões e ao seu império
queria agradecer que todos vocês mas não
só os professores
obrigado
[Música]